actor Anthony Rapp known for Star Trek
discovery and rent alleges Kevin Spacey
made a sexual advance towards him when
he was only 14 years old rap detailed
the events of the night in 1986 to
BuzzFeed news according to rap he was
invited to a party at Kevin Spacey's
home where he spent much of the night
watching TV and Spacey's bedroom alone
given he was the only non adult at the
party after the party ended sometime
past midnight rap alleges Spacey entered
the room seeming drunk he then picked up
rap placed him on Spacey's bed climbed
on top of him and tried to seduce him
rap added Spacey was holding him down
while tightening his grip on rap who was
able to get away after a short time rap
said in a statement to ET quote I came
forward with my story standing on the
shoulders of the many courageous women
and men who have been speaking out to
shine a light and hopefully make a
difference as they have done for me et
has reached out to Kevin Spacey's team
for comment
you